si la condición inicial pasa por el
punto 06 cuál es el rango de la curva
solución de igual a fx para x mayor o
igual a cero entonces aquí tenemos un
campo dependientes para una ecuación
diferencial y estamos diciendo bien si
tenemos una solución donde la condición
inicial pasa por este punto pasa por el
punto 06 entonces 0.6 es parte de esa
solución
veamos ubicamos primero el punto 06 es
este de aquí y va a ser parte de nuestra
solución y queremos saber el rango de la
curva solución y la podemos ver
fácilmente si observamos fijamente el
campo dependientes y así puedes ver que
cuando x aumentan bueno puedes
distinguir que la pendiente está
disminuyendo pero si observas va a
seguir disminuyendo en una tasa más y
más y más lenta y además parece que
tenemos como a sin total a la recta
igual a 4 así que cuando x se hace más y
más más grande
vamos a estar infinitamente cerca de la
recta de igual a 4 pero nunca vamos a
tocar esa recta es decir nunca vamos a
tomar ese valor así que el rango son los
valores de james que esta solución va a
tomar y va a ser bueno observar va a ser
mayores que 4 nunca vamos a ser igual a
4 nos vamos a acercar mucho pero nunca
vamos a ser iguales a 4 entonces va a
ser mayor que 4 esto en el extremo
inferior de mi rango y en el extremo
superior de mi rango sería hasta 6 y de
hecho si tocamos el 6 entonces va a ser
igual a 6 ahora otra forma en la que
pude haber escrito esto mismo es decir
que 4 es menor que james que a su vez es
menor o igual que 6 en cualquier caso
esta es una manera de escribir el rango
es decir los valores de james que la
solución va a tomar para x mayor o igual
a 0
si dijeran para todas las x bueno
entonces pueden haber sido capaces de
volver al 0.6 y continuar del lado
izquierdo pero observan están diciendo
de la curva solución para x mayor o
igual a cero así que no vamos a
considerar esos valores de x menores que
0 y aquí está la curva va a verse algo
así pueden ver que el valor máximo que
toman es a 6 justo aquí y en realidad si
toma ese valor ya que estamos incluyendo
lo cuando x vale 0 y luego sigue bajando
bajando bajando y aproximándose a 4
yendo muy muy muy muy cerca de 4 pero
nunca vamos a ser iguales a 4